a possible payload of mass effect for
details has emerged online offering some
suggestion to the game's key features
and premise of course at this point i
should say possible may be real but
could be false but might also be true
spoilers ahead you've been warned the
new details first appeared on reddit
purportedly taken from an online survey
that was shown to a fan of the series
while many insists the survey is genuine
there's no solid evidence to prove it
the standout fax from the alleged mass
effect force survey suggests that the
game will be distinctly separate from
the previous trilogy and will take on
the role of a new hero eight Pathfinder
Explorer searching for a new home for
Humanity in a game world said to be
several times bigger than mass effect 3
players will be able to explore hundreds
of solar systems some gameplay
components from the original trilogy
will still exist in Mass Effect for such
as the option to choose two teammates to
bring with you on individual missions in
terms of interstellar exploration
players may be able to build settlements
on habitable planets the type of which
will provide various bonuses it also
appears that developer Bioware wants to
introduce major technological feats with
the game apparently able to let players
transition between flying ship to
landing on Planet to driving Mako to
getting out on foot all seamless with no
loading screens meanwhile among the game
side quests is the option to raid
ancient ruins and activating remnant
monoliths which will reward players with
valuable loot and crafting resources
should the survey details prove to be
accurate it should be noted that these
are potential design ideas and not
necessarily features already designed
and coded it's unclear why EA would
release sensitive details about one of
its upcoming games if it has at all
though it should be noted the
corporation has done so more than once
in the past four games like Dragon Age
Inquisition anyway for the full list of
features listed from reddit you can head
over to gamespot calm and stay tuned for
all your other gaming news updates
you